And what about any metrics,
or things that you measured,
which you thought were
important that weren't?
>> So, I don't know if this exactly
is what you're looking for, but
I can definitely think of
situations where metrics
told us a story that didn't really match
reality, and in one of these situations,
we went through a period of time where
our growth was really, really fast.
We were acquiring new MRR, monthly
recurring revenue, very, very quickly,
and we put that number up on the board
every month, and everybody was cheering,
and one of the things we started
noticing that while our new MRR growth
was going up and up and
up our churn numbers were also going up.
So we had customers that were falling
out of the back of the pipeline as well.
And for anybody who's been
involved in a SaaS business,
your churn is one of the most important
metrics to track, because it means that
when it's high you've got a leaky
bucket and you need to work harder and
harder to fill that bucket
while water pours out of it.
And when we dug into it,
it turns out that we had been giving
new customers a short amount of time
where they could do a trial with us and
then forcing them to make a big decision
after that amount of time was up.
And for a lot of these bigger companies
that we never really worked with before,
this just wasn't enough time, and so
they would start a trial, they would get
to the end of this trial and they
wouldn't be ready to actually commit or
not, and they would fall out,
they would churn out.
And so while we were able to, because
of these short trials we were able
to sort of say,
hey there's no commitment up front, we
were able to get a lot of new revenue in
through the door, we also were creating
a situation where ultimately we didn't
provide a good customer experience.
And so that was a situation where we had
a metric which looked really great, but
there was something underneath
that we hadn't seen that was
pretty important to pay attention to.